okay hi everyone and welcome to this
live coding competition be people here
on in the Twitterverse watching this
live streamed and they're also a group
of contestants here still virtual at our
annual war from summer school um and I
should say that the ability to do live
coding as a spectator sport is something
that is pretty unique to often language
because we have a language in which a
lot can be achieved with a small amount
of code in a small amount of time by
sufficiently talented people and so what
we have here is a sequence of challenge
problems and a number of contestants who
will be will be will be able to see some
of what the code they're writing and be
able to sort of see what's happening in
real time so I should just introduce the
we have the contestants here are at our
annual or from summer school which we've
been doing now so the 18th such or from
summer school and this year we actually
have kind of a new piece to the summer
school that relates to our fundamental
theory of physics actually we have a
total of 88 students at the summer
school only the more courageous of them
will be competing live in this live
coding competition we actually also have
now running our summer camp for high
school students
that's another 45 or 50 people not sure
if we have any contestants from from the
summer camp in our collection today but
anyway the the we've been doing live
coding competitions with both in
language for a few years now there are
all sorts of technical challenges in
making
he's really work as good spectator sport
and we've had additional challenges in
in bringing these to you virtually and
with contestants being virtual Jesse
Friedman has been at the center of
making all this stuff work
so it's Jesse's fault if it doesn't work
but I'm sure it will um we also for our
live commentators here we have film
Eamonn and flip Phillips Phil and flip
have both been involved with with
Wolfram language for a long time flip
for a very very long time since the very
beginnings of wolfing language at um and
it's bundling on the next computer and
all those kinds of things back in the in
the very first years and foot posts had
a distinguished career as a as a
professor and so on since his life in in
Silicon Valley back and back in those
days phil has among other things been
the winner of some live coding
competitions that we've had in previous
years after a life in in finance he has
been a professor and a sports analytics
person and so on so um and I'm not I'm
so I should probably turn over to flip
and Phil to actually get going with our
2020 well from summer school live coding
competition and they can explain how
it's really gonna work I'm just I'm just
telling you my amateur version of how
it's gonna work okay over the flippin
Phil will figure this out wit will
explain to everybody I hope pull over my
window Phil go ahead fire it up I think
there we go yeah we are live so when do
we start question one you want to
explain why don't we go ahead and
explain a little bit how this is gonna
work that's a good idea goofy
ya know yeah I mean it you know maybe
it's up to you or we could just let
everyone try to figure it out we're
going to and as you can see actually if
you're at the leaderboard which there is
a online leaderboard that Phillip is
sharing right now and you can see that
on the left there is a question will
appear right now Phillip has a notebook
up with the with his attempted answers
for the question and then so what's
gonna happen here is that our head
honcho Jessie top architect sorry Jessie
is going to release a question into the
wild all of that all of the participants
will then be able to download the
question work on the question Phillip
and I will chat a little bit about how
their solutions are coming and then at
the end of the window of time after we
get enough submissions we will allow you
the twitch universe to vote on your
favorite answer so this is a little
different than the way we've been doing
live coding in the past where this is a
is a popularity contest is what this is
legit stack the deck yes so so get on
get on Twitter and all you know call
your friends call your mom I know that I
would have my mom watching right now if
at all possible to vote for my answers
not that she would know what my answers
are so so why don't we go ahead and get
it started I'm guessing the participants
already oh by the way so yes the
participants I think as Steven pointed
out they're participants from the
wolfram summer school they are they
range in they range in talent and
experience with the language so that and
that's the cool thing about what we've
got going on for this particular version
of the coding challenge is that we're
going to get a bunch of we're gonna get
answers since there is no right answer
for no singular correct answer
we're gonna get all kinds of great
answers and at all kinds of different
levels of solution here so this this
this looks to be an exciting event here
Philip all right Jesse unleash the
Kraken the first question yes create a
pie chart using the digits of pi
so all right there we go
so and we'll start some questions or
some answers should roll in but at the
same time Phillip and I can kind of
discuss I don't know what so whenever
you see things like this what are the
Mathematica constructs you think about
using right off the top of your head
counts counts yeah yeah my favorite is
always demonstrate and this goes back to
an old Steven thing is like you know I
do an N of Pi you can do this in your
window right like do an N of PI to a
thousand or something and you know it
shows somebody how you can generate you
can generate a million digits of pi in
it not even a second right so yeah so go
ahead and pop one in there okay yeah so
right look here's a thousand digits of
pi before you even you know have
breakfast Andy yeah it looks like Andy
and this looks like this is this is a
this is nuts
I'm loving it this one is Nick okay yeah
real digits is a good that's a good plan
on this one and yeah so you got to make
sure so yes exactly so
we got here yes Andy so oh I only one I
see is Andy's but it's Oh yep there's
there's another one so you can see that
again okay
yeah so you can see that we have
basically some of these are really great
now the neat thing about pie charts -
they're they're interactive things so
you should be able to click on one there
and pop a section out right so does that
work on your on window side you know I
have all deuce well you know oh yeah
you're seeing oh that's right it's
because they're coming across the chat
channel as yeah right you sure can so so
go ahead again the beauty of Mathematica
that we can do that yeah so there's the
notice there's a little tooltip in there
that's given us information about the
the valence of each slice so between
this and and we have of course we have
Aaron whose last name is a fruit so now
we have now I'm hungry I want I and we
have fruit pie yes number two is Nick
yes
Andy I think this is a recent yeah Zay
we had three or four that's three right
now say that's a hard number okay yeah
oh my goodness look at this was three
right yeah and then for its scroll down
there look at that crazy boy Joe this is
this is some epic on its way in here for
for all to see yes I think just way to
show them so it's Andy Nick Jose Joe and
Matt yes
those were the first five yes and so
again loving the idea here that's
actually that's an interesting by the
way go check out that last yeah well go
ahead yeah yeah see look look what we're
getting a statistical distribution of
the digits now right yes so that's
that's pretty slick we're getting a
we're actually getting a real-life
statistical distribution this one let's
see what's going on here we're getting
the oh so this is just all the digits
that he is pulling those from and then
what's going when he Sam yeah Jose oh
he's getting the rest
he got enough pie so he got all of the
dates all of the Dismas points for using
all the digits of five and so the way
real digits works is the first thing it
returns a list of two things the first
is the list of digits in the second is
what's to the left of the decimal point
so this is the first and the rest of the
without three okay yeah yeah yeah that's
pretty slick though so yeah and you
you'd think we'd be waiting here all day
for all the digits but you know yeah so
so according to according to Avery right
now on the pole there is a pole at
twitchtv I believe it's just part of the
it's part of the twitch stream and we're
we're seeing votes now as a matter of
fact where do you see them well I see
them on my screen but oh it's
neck-and-neck get your votes in quick
yeah yeah yeah yeah Mac call your mom
your friends Jose call your friends get
everybody on ten guys if you're watching
on twitch you have to look above the
chats where it says current poll click
that and then you'll be a happy person
yes Oh Matt creeping sprinting forward
is I also wonder I in twitch can you um
can you change your votes and twitch
polls because now things get
and it looks like come from behind nice
so Jose we know we have a secret
here's we just voted at the last second
you'll never guess yeah yeah so scroll
down to Jose's there look at that yeah
and so yes by the way all the
competitors there we apologize that we
may or may not slant votes due to our
things so you're right now you're just
playing to our nerd things that give us
the little bit of nerd excitement over
here all these solutions are great
though by the way this the and and all
of you did them in a in a clever clever
fashion and that's exactly what we're
looking for so the leaderboard on which
has now been updated has Jose so Jose
gets three points Matt two points and
Andy oh no relation to can do I believe
but you never know with one point so we
are off to yes kudos kudos love all
right here comes question two all right
yes yeah all right write a function oh
you want to go ahead and Philip you read
this one I did last nucleotide sequence
yep and a tizzy there we go or Zed
depending on where you're from
that's it well I'm soaked I live so
close to Canada that just by default I
have to call it said Nexus it is it
comes across the lake for those of you
listening I him I'm in lovely I wanted
to say Buffalo New York but I'm not him
in Rochester so I'm even confused where
I am here
okay obtain the sequence for a gene
using genome data so see you've been
given an awesome hint just for starters
and search for an English word in the
result produced by your function and
then oh yeah this is one where we would
like for you to add a just add a text
cell with the method you used for
getting the genetic sequence in you know
so so that Philip and I don't have to
decode mentally what you did yeah
yeah it's as my my years of cognitive
science training have taught me this is
basically but I will say in the last
answer we did use the entirety of Pi so
who said that yeah right and I think
there's gonna be a PNP question at some
point leaked apparently the questions
which was that's good that's good yeah
so just again for for observe outside
observers who are not part of the summer
school we've got this summer school
these students are all working in
cooperation with with Steven and a bunch
of incredibly talented teaching
assistants and they are working on each
of them working on a unique and clever
problem you can go to the Wolfram
website and the Wolfram community site
and have a look at some of the projects
from previous years there's some really
cool projects and this is a chance for
basically for them to come and work on a
dedicated
a project with interaction with top
architects of the Wolfram language
Brooke with Stephen fill up his ear rub
your last year I was doing some TA I did
a TA this year you are doing ta work
right I went to the school oh yeah right
bring 13 years ago myself and it did
change my life so I highly recommend
anybody who's here to enjoy it and who's
not here to apply for next year it's a
it's it's a miraculous thing we'll talk
more about it but what I wanted to point
out a couple things that if you're kind
of new to Wolfram language or you don't
know what's going on some of the amazing
things one of the things that as a
programmer is phenomenal about the
Wolfram language is the help and it goes
underappreciated who cares about the
docs right but they're actually
incredibly valuable yes oh no I was
gonna say it's the it's the number one
it's the most underrated thing a and B
it's you don't even you know the the
integration is amazing right a you know
since the very earliest day so yeah yeah
any other language python or whatever
and you're trying to solve a particular
problem all you could do the docks don't
help you right you have to go to Google
you get some answer that you hope
someone asks it's just very confusing
here it's just a beautiful layout of all
of the help my favorite part is the sea
also and what makes it my favorite part
is if you watch on this Twitter stream
which you have presumably you've been
watching live CEO Inge and one of the
things he does Steven when he's live
seeing is he thinks about how to I
forget what he calls it is it knitting
or threading or threading getting all
these concepts and they don't always go
both ways so this might link to a see
also somewhere else that does not link
back because when you're thinking about
one you'd want to think about it but the
other you wouldn't it's it's it's
curated help which is beautiful
and guess what flip what we have our
first submission oh oh oh my god here we
go
I'm excited here it is well okay I can't
see it though
on my screen can you see it on my screen
nope oh oh you know why because I have
the leaderboard up because I mention hey
okay this is his name so the cell with
his name is not copying so I'll just
type it in this is Matt oh there it is I
got I it has just come over the you'll
you'll all be happy to know that there
is a carrier pigeon based system that is
sending things to me here in Rochester
and so it has just come across so let's
see what Matt did he he took the genome
data for this particular gene he took
the full sequence and it looks like this
I'll just put a semicolon to hide it but
you can see it's a J's and GS and T's
and C's because it's a long string the
whole thing
then he took lowercase and the
characters characters gives a list fine
so now he has a list of the lowercase
characters we all see the text
description of what you did yes
so about what that function there is I
sent one of this function you did yeah
scroll up a little yes I see it I see it
thank you no wait that's Scott's answer
right yeah let me see yours - Matt okay
yeah yeah thank you finally so let me
just paste it here
here's Matt's description of what he did
replace each letter of the sequence with
a random letter and then search for
words in the resulting string Oh
excellent
so you so and and let me see yeah and
you replace them with
let's see you replace them with though
the same random line so you didn't just
get a genetic string and then just
create a random string to match with it
I got it yes that that's good I was
behind by one one clock tick there yeah
that's nice that's a nice collection
okay
wait is that the same thing I copied
yeah it is but this is Scott F oh yeah
why do we have Matt and Scott Oh ignore
Scott Scott yeah ignore Scott yeah yeah
Scott Scott is sending the stuff to me
that's what's happening first solution
great yeah Stan only solution so and by
the way to point something interesting
out that happened there I don't know if
anyone else noticed but when you
evaluated genome data a little blue box
came up and basically and it was because
you didn't have the genome data on your
machine and then so this is a speaking
of program early cool things this is
basically the data for that is gigantic
and not everyone will need and/or want
that data so it first of all it isn't
shipped with it but a link to it out in
the universe is shipped and so and it
took I just I downloaded it just now and
it literally took four seconds and I got
all this genome data and that way you
don't have to the system is big but it's
even bigger and it's curated and kept up
to date so if the if the genetic data
changes you know due to mutation or
other terrifying events of alien events
you know right you you're getting you
can get the data is up-to-date and if it
doesn't change or you're not on the
internet once you've gotten at once it
has been downloaded and is good for you
to use so it's solid it's it's a really
clever thing it is it's awesome all
right so here's the original answer by
Matt that all these cool words yeah you
broke it dude no you got root I always
and busted your code I'm so sorry so can
anyone on twitch what's why is that why
is it when I run this code I get a
different answer than an eagle yeah for
the love of God
someone telling this solve this mystery
we're scooby-doo
it's always the guy underneath the mask
it's always that guy now and when I run
it by the way I get film like zany flee
fuse pour odor stop work
don't play perfect words for you yeah
they really are
they I'd like to think someone put this
together you not only answer the
question you also created a personality
assessment yeah I was built in there
from the beginning yeah yeah it must be
the random feed that you don't use right
oh good so yes lord massacree and yeah
weird magic ray very good it's it's
random that's right because it's random
every time
how about pseudo random is what I would
say but that's just me because it's a
deterministic random Oh No somebody call
coma Gore off or Greg Chayton quickly
let us get him there yeah this is really
good this is this is yeah yeah yeah you
never get if you're sick of pseudo
random and you want to just get if you
want random
this is random is this coming quantum
random so this is freely really random
like this there's a version of you
that's looking at a different 1,024
letters right now yeah so we just split
your life into a thousand pieces who's
next
sounds like my marriage I'm very I'm
happy we're all I'd be the big happy
family we have another we got another
answer from Nick here we go all right
Nick who Nick I like some of what I like
the coudé that's happening this is nice
as a function yeah it's a function DNA
alphabet from a string and then he uses
this genome day
thanks for the word and dictionary word
q where's the text description yeah yeah
text description of what you have
accomplished what you have here and by
the way I want to know did so and he
picked a different gene and I'm gonna
I'm gonna look these genes up on the
side to find help are you watching
expert no I well I've no no no but I I
have you know you never know so some of
these are fun right this is the gene for
you know your pinky toe curves right
word or something so let's see if
there's any secret if these guys are
trying to be too clever by half this
looks like an interesting so so so
Knicks gene is the epithelial sodium
chance so it's a sodium channel gene so
it's one of those things when people are
sending in their solutions it would be
great to know why they picked the gene
they did ya know that's why that's why
I'm sign it go on the room right we
don't want to violate hip or anything
yeah yeah yeah yeah interesting to know
how many genes are there well depends
humans animals there there there are how
many have we found you know enough let's
see here
oh so 5-ht 33 see to the one that the
previous one is yeah it's it's the you
can use these nick thing i've seen the
the cards for these anyway we have an
answer from twitch there are precisely
14 genes no that's good i'm glad they're
only 14 okay so matt says his was the
first in the drop-down menu and nick use
the one from the documentation there you
go
so they yeah right chosen using very
method you know the best method is the
documentation this is great so I don't
really understand what's happening here
yeah no I'm trying to so let's work it
out from by the way of in the debugger e
universe here that we all like to live
in i i i learned lisp before i got all
tied up in this and write the way you
kind of work from the inside to try to
figure out how these to figure out what
he's doing right so we can use this as a
great moment to to show the students
kind of what that's doing so we're given
a string first thing he does is letter
number letter number places everything
with a number of the letter you can give
it a string right and it'll give the
letters the numbers so you have numbers
from 1 to 26 no you only have four right
do you have four numbers what is a
stranger
yeah I've never done it for a string oh
yeah there you go
yeah digits effaced love this okay and
then partitions them into groups of five
groups of five base to letter number
representations yes yeah you got to
flatten them all out right that's it
back from binary to decimal yeah mod 28
by 28
hey throw Z plus the two jokers at the
maybe there are some missing letters
like zit yeah okay well zero is space I
know in the letter number universe it
always gives 0 for space
so anyone okay then he adds one
uppercase string joint okay so it's
groups of five oh why is it groups of
five yeah to the fifth all right yeah
there we go like that I like that yep
yeah so every sequence of five letters
basically he creates into okay very
interesting approach yep string link
yeah there's my favorite now cuz you
evaluated yeah there you go
I didn't know I didn't know DPT that's
in the dick I guess it's cuz it's yeah I
don't know must be a thing ADA
Lovelace's make gets a shout out there
we go this is awesome
there we go it's like almost a complete
sentence ada DPT huh
yeah pat Hanrahan my old office made at
Pixar is packed PhD so I I worked on
everything before the movies so I was
there I was the I worked on commercials
and I worked on the short films the one
Oscar yeah that's awesome yeah
those were good days alright so we're
gonna give you one more minute on the
leaderboard clock so it says 442 right
now we're gonna give you until 4:00 43
and 15 seconds because why because we
can volume volume volume so it's for 42
we're gonna give you two for 43 and 15
by the way feel free to submit if you're
gonna if you're gonna basically end up
at 4-4 if you're gonna end up with
something that almost worked or whatever
go ahead and deliver that as well for
voting because you know this since this
is a this is all about giving it a
good try while we're at it yeah so this
is for twitch this is not the deadline
for you to vote this is the deadline for
the coders to write code and then you'll
have your own deadline for voting this
is a tough question yeah really is this
is this is one that I when I look
through I the other ones I had kind of
an idea of how I was gonna start you're
smart you're prepared you look through
yeah well at fresh yeah good no no this
is enough so here we have Matt ah so we
got a third one has just rub a third oh
wow that's a lot of stuff yeah and by
the way that's that's it so time up
answers and pencils down this is going
to be text explanation so yellow
saint-jean no use of semicolon I would
like to all programmers realize that
semicolon is your friend all right what
do we got okay
replace something and it string cases of
that so appears within his solutions yes
yeah legitimate solution there's no text
so we don't know what he did so who's so
the three voting are Jose Nick and Matt
oh yes so Avery's pulling the put in the
poll together and it is live the poll is
live I repeat but you can look up on the
poll again so let's review this was Matt
basically replace each letter with a
random letter Nick's which we don't have
a text description but we sort of
figured out it's using like a sliding
five character scale to get a number
from one to twenty six in a
deterministic way which I've effectively
ends up creating some kind of sentence
and joses which we're not
totally sure what happened like what
he's doing I mean oh he's adding a
random integer okay so he's basically
doing random as well
right right three or three choices and
right now it appears Matt is in the lead
I like the I like the the Nik solution
because of the kind of sliding window
idea now once we figured that out it is
interesting how yeah right you did yeah
I mean one thing you could do is you
could look at patterns of pairs right I
would that's exactly what I was thinking
about engrams all right we got about a
minute left in the poll everybody so get
your votes in oh there was your question
what is flattened I'll show you have a
lift that has like lists inside lists
inside lists inside lists if you have
lots of lists and you're like man that's
too many lists I'd like it all as one
list please mr. Lighton is your friend
boom the timer the timer to vote is
almost over looks like matt is
dominating the votes he's gotten all
he's gotten the the inlaws the distant
cousins oh I just got a text from my mom
mom voted for Matt on this one and not
me so and it's over and Matt is our
winner
on this one so three points for Matt -
for Nick and one for Jose so see Jose he
submitted you there's there's credit you
get this question number three let's see
all right
so Nick is on the board with two points
a very solid start yes Matt crushing it
was a very close second Mandy still here
very good yeah
so Jose that keeping it you know the
slow and steady when
the race there so we're getting good all
right Jesse number three please if you
would create a depiction yeah this one
this this is good create a depiction of
a flower using any Wolfram language
visualization functionality eg needs to
be a comma there my copy editor symbolic
graphics graph plotting equation
plotting etc you should create your
solution should create an image or
drawing from scratch rather than loading
or using one from another source
this means no web image search or
Wolfram Alpha popular curves however in
my you know write my first my first
impression is if if the goal is to get
the answer there first web image search
and we're done this this by the way has
a very Mike trot flavor to it right and
but of course there's the popular curves
thing now so it'll be you know this but
now so so let's think about this how
would you how would what is your what is
your thinking about how you would go out
go about doing this one yeah once I get
to the neural net repository some kind
of images yeah it's a good question
turning oranges into apples this is so
cool yeah which one of these is fun
totally built-in so you can eat sketch I
like this one generate hand-drawn
sketches yeah so you click on it it
shows code with one click look at this
net evaluate of this neural net you just
telling what you want let's try up so
we'll give it a go paste it it's like
the easiest programming in the world
yeah come on I'm doing machine learning
net evaluate oops Wow see if that works
that would be great
come on neural net I have to apologize
my computer does not have a GPU oh yeah
we got so again it goes and gets a
version of the network off of the
repository yeah it's a big Network it's
17 megabytes that's so that's a lot of
floppy disks and you're yeah you're 1200
baud modem is is screaming underneath
you yeah oh my God look at that gonna be
good that's that is the cutest thing
I've ever seen
here comes five from work few things oh
just like something my kid would do this
is a really cool net cuz it's uh it's
from this game quick-draw Oh was it okay
quick quick draw so right you're it
you're told what to draw and and they
store it so they know all of the strokes
that you use to store something and then
they train it cuz it's obviously labeled
yeah and then you can generate it this
is the computer basically daydreaming
about flowers yeah give it something
else give us like a I don't know I mean
a house I know it doesn't know house
okay alarm clock yeah there you go it's
like a house yeah it's the reason I
asked i oh look it has a different no so
it's getting the train net for each of
the for each of the different targets so
it's got a it's got a net trained for
each one first by Matt with a rainbow
that's beautiful isn't it yeah I was
gonna sing Rainbow Connection but they
can't yeah anyway Matt mind if axes
do that I don't think you would mind no
I didn't I would encourage it it's a
matter of policy yeah that's interesting
yeah that's a second virus in situs
quick-draw yeah yeah oh my god I thought
like an hour ago
yeah and now we have another solution
I'm looking at some beautiful wit yours
you see another one yeah yeah Nick just
fired one off why don't we switch to
your screen then cuz mines okay hold on
here oh so I am seeing I'm what I'm
gonna show you because I let's see here
you ready go week oh sorry I don't quite
have a you just announced that Jeremy
iwk announced his love for Matt he says
Matt I love you but that is absolutely
not a flower okay
that's yeah yeah that's pretty epic all
right hold on here and so we go over to
mine here so here is this one is NYX let
me know when you get back I'm just gonna
need all this stuff here okay whoops I
got the wrong it turns out that as smart
as chrome is I can't run well I can I
could have done Mathematica I could have
used the I could have used web
Mathematica for this yeah here we go
yeah I know yeah I got it sorry no this
is yeah this is where in the and it's oh
yeah look at that crazy thing here this
is gorgeous
second solution is by which one are you
looking at right now I'm looking at the
second solution so Nick yeah let's see
here so what what did Nick do Nick
according to this data calm did the
complex plot
get the the festive background colors
and then used oh now this this is kind
of a cool feature that we should
probably talk about right the idea of
using these resource functions they
allow to extend the language in a
systematic way and so these are stored
out in the global universe and so that's
where I guess he got that nested
branching I didn't know that was a
resource function then we have a
gorgeous yeah yeah this is really nice
and this was who's this was Nick's Nick
yeah that's so this is basically an
l-system kind of a thing happening there
so that's pretty sweet and then we got a
Pavel sent us this guy again elegance
style like a spaceship - yeah yeah yeah
all right so we got about one minute
left so hold on Aaron I'll go back we'll
do the same thing we did before let me
know when you whenever if you when you
would like to still dying yeah this
happens so it's for 55 we're gonna stop
at 456 so go ahead and send whatever you
want now let's see it looks like we got
a fourth one this is good by the way as
a vision scientist I have Jesse have a
little chat window from Jesse open on in
my peripheral vision and it's easier for
me to do to see that than it is for me
to actually watch it because peripheral
vision the acuity here we go this is
this is pretty sweet to look at this
thing looks like a sunflower
oh nice we have a fourth and the
question is now closed just in time just
in time and this one's this is Joe
Crowley's
kind of this cool branching
and and he's doing it he made a
parametric region that he rotated over
and over and over so we have the pole
should be going live now yeah and hold
on I'll go back here just so we have it
so here's Matt's right here sorry I
didn't have maths in my so there's Matt
this is Nick's again cool use of
resource function we've got Pavel and
we've got Joe Crowley right there so the
pole is live very nice yeah here I'll
add that just as yeah this so because
the school is going on there's a chat
and this is from el Bronco 93 yeah yeah
this is cool by the way this isn't in
the poll oh that's from twitch actual
yeah good job twitch awesome yes way to
go twitch so let's see so Matt Nick
Pavel and Joe and the poll right now
illuminant dominant dominant running
away with it we may have a we may have a
tie for third get your votes in yeah the
excitement all the glory by the way good
job twitch this is the allowing the the
outside twitch viewer to play when's the
last time you could do that plan your
video I don't know if Animal Crossing on
a I got nothing I don't know so my
Colonels back I'm ready any time okay
good
so we're back to five four three Oh Nick
you dominated well done Nick and well
done Pavel and Joe
tie yep and so we'll see how that is
gonna be laid out in the leaderboard I'm
gonna stop sharing let you go back to
sharing there we go we're waiting for
these to update yeah I don't know
you know there's right I did this we
didn't talk about this at the at all the
planning meetings about what happens
with a tie it during I'm sure I'm sure
we did and I just wasn't listening
buggin right it's probably yeah or will
it or will just will will poor Matt get
nothing right because of the
distribution of the points will it be
okay fair Jose very close Joe and Andy
oh here we go
and come back Andy where you at yeah if
we miss you Andy all right here we go
question for bring it Jesse bring the
hurt list functions pick any function
listed on the documentation guide page
rearranging and restructuring lists and
look there's even a handy link in there
and create a function that reimplemented
basic functionality of the original
without using the original function in
your new function so it's kind of like
you know whatever this is a submission
yeah you think so
oh the one in the that would violate the
rule this is the old you know dictionary
words should not use the word itself in
the definition of the dictionary
that would be a good view good program
puzzles see if you can find a definition
that actually does use yeah yeah yeah
there you go we got all right so
rearranging and restructuring this in
your work from language flip would you
say where would you rank rearranging and
restructuring lists on your you know
I'll tell you what it's one of those it
depends I kind of use Wolfram language
in two different ways and or for two
main tasks in my data analysis universe
where I'm taking data generated by
experiments or other things rearranging
and restructuring lists is about the
number one you know thing you're doing
there right you're trying to answer
eight and clean up your data and then
but what it what you realize is the kind
of scalability of all that is that you
end up rearranging and restructuring
even for things that are not list based
right so so that's kind of how I use it
yeah Phillip you should bring up the the
doc page itself and show everybody what
should show the Twitterverse that
beautiful link here we go so here we
have to choose a any function listed on
this guide page by the way these guide
pages are also really cool they're there
any other page that looks like this that
you see on the web was all definitely
created by a computer right and you can
tell by reading it it's gonna involve
functions that no one cares about you
know but this is all human curated it's
not even an alphabetical order right
it's really most important first it's
almost like it's trying to read your
mind and it's in groups of chunks and
sometimes I don't know if this has one
but if there's too many examples this
one doesn't have any but we have like
three dots then there's a further guide
yep
and by the way the there is a there's a
method to that madness
everyone should also realize that the
that there are guide pages there are
application pages right so there are
things so the idea is that there's a
nice documentation of the function but
then there are these kind of meh there
are meta page
then there are also workflows right and
all those things and I know that when I
teach my students you know when I work
with my students this is always
important is to remind them to not just
you like if you're using riffle for
example to just not only look at the
documentation page you got to look at
all those see also and and all that
stuff yes it looks like we got an answer
there we do we have our first solution
by Pablo looks like he's going to be
implementing captain eight captain eight
we had the definition here it captain
eights elements from a list of lists
what's an example usage of it you can
catenate it's like flatten right it puts
it all together yep
and his solution involves flatten very
reasonable yes goods good plan and he
called it cake which is fish instead of
Kate Nate what a crazy english-language
you read this you say captain eight but
it's really Kate yeah it's Kate mate
yeah it is
I'm like as Kate gives the exact same
solution it sure does here's a one-liner
yes yes introduced let's see this was in
ta 14 yeah it's the difference between
catenate if you know that's a good
question I think it puts them in isn't
it something about them being in canaan
canonical listen to me speaking
canonical order or is there something
like that as a it's the association's
thing how could be cuz if you try to put
a copy that and slap a flattered Ivan in
don't copy it just slap a flat in there
oh by the way that's the cool part
another cool part about the
documentation you can literally evaluate
inside the documentation itself right
when's the last time you did that at
home with your yeah I'm ain't with
Fortran 77 yeah so yes yeah it looks
like it doesn't work across the it
doesn't work across associations Yeah
right this is what you want
right right no good solution Nick what
the name is the best so yeah he's
reimplemented sort sort sort works
wonderfully right it's optimized let's
see if it's not yet sorted yes
shuffle it shuffle it this otherwise
you're done yeah this is the world's
best yeah yeah I'm just gonna shuffle it
until it gives me the answer that I want
that's yeah that's beautiful
yeah that's class gorgeous yes I don't
know we should give it I don't know
let's see how it's going we got we have
we have behind the scenes our research
team is informing us about captain eight
okay 100 only the first level there we
go example if I have nested lists ah
so captain eight is right more like
flatten is flattening but one yeah okay
alright i buy that cool would just do
this and see it'll tell you if two
functions are equal right yeah I'm sure
that I was gonna say yeah the I'm sure
the theorem automated they're improving
people are are all good on that this is
question for to my counting correctly
yes and so so I get from the control
booth from the guys in the control booth
I'm saying a few more minutes so we'll
stop this question at what's called 509
so you're specific yeah I like it how
about how about 508 and 58 seconds yeah
5:09 it says let's go back to these
functions because yeah yeah it could be
a little overwhelming at first learning
a language - oh my god like 5,000
functions of learning a human language
yes how do you tend to think about
learning other functions that you've
never seen yeah that's a you know
honestly the way that I do is I try to
find and this is an a beautiful
documentation feature is like for
example click on whatever array flatten
there and I literally go to scroll to
the very bottom of you see that see also
there I'm sorry I guess back up that
gives me an idea again human curated
goodness here the and and the way and if
you've ever watched by the way the any
of the coding even any of Stephens you
know design reviews and things all the
developers have the documentation tools
integrated into their universe and
they're trying to use them as they you
know as they develop code and so that
allows for the curation of those things
down there at the bottom
right you and you know that oh yeah this
is like flatten or join or band and it
so it allows me to it'll out the the
documentation itself gives you the
chance to find things that are close to
the thing you think you may or may not
know what it is yeah that's some
terrible these properties it's a little
advanced but these properties and
relations yes this is what I use least
when I use it it always helps yes yeah
yeah yeah good point very good point I'm
really really stuck well we have another
solution from Jose okay oh good Jose
keeping it real we got yeah we are my
clock might be wrong I'm not sure and I
don't know what time it is oh no it's
over
welcome back Andy oh and we have a
solution from and eosin alright see your
solutions alright have bowel solutions
for catenate we have Nick's solution for
sorting we
josè solution for let's see oh this is
yes very nice split and it's very cool
sequence cases is new I like and and I
like the repeated pattern match that's a
that so again you just wouldn't think
about that off the top of your head the
you know the repeated character pattern
match that he's got a good one yeah yeah
good thing and EO has a built-in secret
function new reverse the source code has
been hidden so we're not sure what the
solution is but he's demonstrated beyond
a shadow of a doubt that is definitely
works yes and there and indeed MEK might
be might be part of some hidden package
oh there it is so here's Osho he's so if
you wolf go look in the if you look in
the slack oh no now it's got it yep
there we go thank you thank you everyone
sometimes we need we need a little help
here new reverse join map indexed very
good yeah I love map indexed and map
indexed is like a version one thing that
when I first saw it in the language it
was like when would I ever use that and
then I later on it's like why don't I
use that all the time it's an it's an
amazing one so this is to summarize for
the poll we have Powell with captain
eight Nick with the world's greatest
sort Jose with the homebrew of split and
a do back from wherever he was with a
new improvement reverse alright the poll
is live the play live and if we were to
close it now Jose would dominate with
one oh no now it's tied with host which
is working for everybody right like it's
continuing to show live mine Sevilla
broken I feel like I'm back in Saratoga
watching races at the track yeah
and EO coming around the Pogues this is
a tight one yeah I like this this is
good this shows again these solutions
are creative and clever very it's a good
question
I mean I'm gonna say I like this is I'm
kind of kind of tilt in my hand that I
love the absurdity of best or it wins
the best is it is it the best
reimplementation of something no no it's
the worst so so Nick wins both the best
and the worst yeah there's a there's a
iterative algorithm used in
psychophysics called past and then
someone came up with something called
the best past and it's like oh please
and then someone came up with quest
that's better than past and now there's
a thing called quest plus and it's like
you know we're gonna have quest + + +
rhyming so it looks like Nick is Nick is
winning the poll based on the absurdity
index come on no no certainly not me -
it's more in the spirit of what like you
know really reimplemented from scratch
in a way you know this could definitely
work yep and you know that one of the
fun things back when I used to when I
used to work there you know to have
access to some of this is to look at
some of the implementations of some of
these things is really spectacular
because in your brain that's one of the
cool things about the resource function
universe is that the source code is
there for you to go in and look it does
what it does so that l-system thing that
Nick did earlier if you want to do that
Oh Nick the winner
I'm feeling a I'm feeling a belt
yeah someone someone should put that up
the results are in right yeah first
place in Jose and Paulo
overall it's Nick but how do you say it
Nick by a hair Nick Nick my nose then
Jose and Matt really close Pawel Joe is
back welcome back ready for question
five bring it last question no I can't
remember and we will find out will get
will get from the tower create a simple
graphical dashboard textual weather
report or other display communicating
some information about the current
weather in a city of your choice so I
have a I have a feeling that the city
what may impact heavily on to one's
ability to score high points so if you
know where your audience is right now
interesting yeah right less data for you
to display yep so we're hearing from the
tower yeah there's a total of six
questions yes with the potential for a
tiebreaker if needed yes with a
tiebreaker as needed now wait now
there's fighting in the tower it appears
that the it appears that there are now
people throwing various pieces of
clipboard and it's like airplane I think
Scott is someone sniffing glue
someone is oh no there's been a
concession in the control tower
somewhere he's down in three counts by
submission ladies and gentlemen it's got
Fischer the winner in the control tower
so we're gonna go six questions at the
wrong week that's right Johnny
- but how would you think about doing a
dashboard your visual guy your where are
you let's see I'm a I don't know I would
I love I'm a personally and I I'm also a
weather nerd - I got a I could turn my
camera around you could see my weather
stations outside really yeah I'm that
guy
the I'm a minimalist you know a best use
of space kind of thing so I love
clusters of easy to read from far away
information you know dials and gauges
are fine if you're if you've only got
one or two but you know if you can if
there's a way to kind of consolidate
like if it's the temperature I don't
know I'm thinking of ideas what about
you like like maybe temperature if it's
it's hot that 95 should be bigger maybe
not a different color I'm colorblind
here lady isn't color anomalous you know
so go with size okay okay that's a
thought part of your minimalism like you
have it all hooked up by the way the red
light right now it just goes on right
the past couple of days for any of you
who are not in the Northeast right now
it's just right now it's just pegged at
you know go to the bunker right now I
don't know where some of you are it's
got to be more comfortable than weather
data and bright forecast data now nice
nice nice and and now they're asking for
a report which is interesting but I
still I like the idea of forecast or at
least now casting you know near casting
as well you know no what's it gonna be
like in the next you know twenty minutes
and by the way speaking of cool he is
speaking of cool like geographic things
here how about that is that not the most
useful crazy function still still bugs
me a little white why is he here not a
function is not a function yeah now
go to those design meetings is what we
got to do it's just doing some kind of
magic yeah right right
today now all these things yeah they
really they kind of know right yeah this
is awesome it's so there it uses the
time series encapsulation data
encapsulation which I which I just love
all to death and so it's coming so it
looks like it's hourly right and there's
all these cool functions like data that
linear model fit that properties you can
get from yes yeah yeah and so using that
properties thing is a beautiful right
that's a now this is an association of
time series which is by the way this
this is good this is a good
implementation note for those of you
when you're developing your own
functions to do things it's often very
useful to look at similar fun so if I
needed something rather than creating a
time series that had a bunch of paths in
it for cloud cover
temperature and humidity just one time
series this is a much better way it what
you should do is look at the way that
the data is returned from a Wolfram
function because there will clear there
will be ways that the rest of the system
is designed to use the output of the
functions that are built into Wolfram if
that makes sense into the Wolfram
language so so that the looking at this
right here's the max temperature
function right this right I haven't been
outside in a long time with visible from
summer school
yeah is it really this hot outside it
it's hotter than that here so yeah my
gears let's say I don't know I was just
it's funny you just mentioned this yeah
no I look out the window right now it's
96 degrees in that
it's been that hot in Rochester since at
least it's not snowing this has been my
how we doing on do we have any no no
answers yet still see here yeah go ahead
and try so what uh Philip you're the the
as you so you you came into the language
when it's almost like you yes if you
like the version I remember reading the
Mathematica book for version four okay
oh good so early on so but but and I
liked it because my dad had written I
credit derivatives price are way back
then and Wolff language mathematics to
handle it but then my mind I remember my
mind being first blown with version six
manipulate yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yes oh hey we got an answer we have
two answers one answer repeat agreed and
sent in again thanks Matt Matt here we
go Matt's first solution is this
dashboard very nice there you go I'll
rerun it here and then we can compare
yeah right all right this would be an
interesting project if somebody gives
you a random time of day the information
can you okay it's colder there and let's
see here I'll paste mine into our chat
great yeah sure you guess we're in the
world so where Matt is oh good it's only
up to 33 here now right now this one's
yours right yeah yeah yeah yeah 33 wow
so you're the hottest and you're also
the most north most northerners you also
have wind yeah yeah let's do it
a dataset my a Nanami turret is spinning
I am looking outside right now it is
yeah it's cuz it's it's the little thing
gold cups that go around in the search
dataset was another thing that and their
Nations
yeah yeah in my mind and that's
something that luckily
each it reminds me a lot of the neural
network and image processing stuff is
each iteration you know the things are
getting a little better the the people
have figured out more comfortable ways
to use this oh you got a Association
those I think you're right thank you
maybe there's by the way notice of
consumers that he typed to Association
and it basically was blue which means in
tactically that does not exist there we
go
almost you got them yeah and you got a
deeper you could you could just yeah
right
yep there we go there we go alright so
matt has the is in a cloudy area with
higher humidity than us and cold it's
freezing there and no wind yeah but yeah
and high pressure so that means that the
weather has not right the that's usually
he's sitting in the middle of a
high-pressure circle by the way well
we'll give you another so it's 524 so
let's give you until 526 we could do 527
from you let's do I like that I like
that we have a solution from a Geo Hindi
is gonna I want Andy to feel strongly
about this Andy to bring this back I'll
maybe something yeah it does thank you
so we know we're an do is yes or at
least we know that he chose Boston yes
okay neat so you could choose each one
and it'll yeah yeah that did it
shouldn't that work why don't we do we
got another one from and we got a big
like this crazy looking thing from Jose
yeah buddy cool cool I'm not sure how to
debug yours there's something yeah you
you you go ahead and get Jose's and I'll
see if I can figure out what's going on
it's a picture okay so delete missing
weather data of Lisbon Portugal
okay well Jose you you could just do
weather data of Lisbon I think it
returns that's the Association got back
anyway right yeah it looks like what he
did I find myself doing this a lot too
and flipped if you have a tip for how to
do it better I'd appreciate it if you go
to weather data or this also this
happens a lot and classify and predict
there's a list of possible things that
you can ask for right like cloud cover
fraction cloud hide the properties yeah
if I want to see them all sometimes I
copy paste and use each each one I use I
have a little function I wrote that
tries to figure out what the properties
are for things that are so some of these
things you can actually you know ask for
the properties and then I do a map onto
the properties list and it makes this
giant and I turn that into a data set
it's kind of like the way that new
function information have you seen that
function and its use I have information
is very cool yeah and it and I don't
know if it I
you know some things it works on and
again this is something I'm kind of
hoping that it gets a little better
where it shows you all the properties
you know when you when you use when so
they they've functions like information
so instead of just using the question
mark there are some of these things that
are getting more and more sophisticated
in terms of the things that though and I
was wrong Jose you were right you do
have to do it this way whether data does
not seem to allow weather forecast data
did the weather data does not and looks
like we have our last solution alright
here comes our last solution ringing the
bell here we go it is by Joe Crowley
here we go dashboard that is a dashboard
and a half I feel I'm feeling the
dashboard
all right excellent very good right here
our nominees Joe Crowley with this
dashboard putting it in order nice right
we have Jose don't hold this looks like
he was a problem on our end not on his
he sent the correct code and it gave all
this information that was Jose for
Lisbon
Andy Andy's also may be our fault not
clear but we know what it's doing right
it's yeah yeah if you want to see
pressure temperature wind speed and it
shows weather data back to 2008
that's Andy OH Matt Matt gave us these
these particular specific things for the
location where he's at very good right
that's it so those are our choices we
have Matt Andy Oh Jose and Joe and let's
see if those people in the chat are
saying that you've missed two of them I
have missed two of them Chad is never
wrong
no oh I missed it Jesse no that's that's
yeah no I didn't miss wait this is and
then there's mine at the bottom but
that's just me yeah yeah yeah yeah no no
no no yeah
yeah papel and nick poses this one for
Warsaw very good and now we have Nick
yeah Nick with his icons everybody ready
Nick with his icons look at that this is
all code
he has no cloud data where he is that's
hilarious beautiful look at that we have
Nick Powell Joe Jose Jose Andy oh and
Matt yeah this is good if we got
together
Joe is not going in the poll I apologize
why I don't know okay yeah yeah the
tower over oh that's right we've we were
limiting it to five questions because of
the poll right all right the poll can
the Pogo live poll can go live can do
off to an early lead and you know and
Jose fighting it out with Mama's little
helper coming from behind helping
pushing Nick forward so that I gotta say
I the Nick and Pavel solutions those
lighter ones they are they answer the
spirit of the question right a small
dashboard definitely so and this is the
sort of thing you'd want outside your
house right yeah no that's exactly what
I want
yes you don't need the labels because
you can tell what it is yeah yeah yeah
yeah confuse about dashboards in general
obviously this is you know in five
minutes but in general in building
dashboards it's one of the most amazing
things that language is good at it used
to be ten fifteen years ago maybe even
as recently as five years ago and until
today in some companies if you can make
a dashboard in Excel Wow yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah anything
yeah everyone hires you and loves you
but you can make these kinds of
dashboards that bet with just one
additional cloud publisher
on all of these live yep done yeah for
your location in every other location
and yeah no I again yeah that's really
some of the some of the slickest stuff
is when you can deploy stuff like that
with literally a rapper that's just
awesome so we have it looks like we got
about 10 seconds and yeah we're gonna go
to jumps out just a question for you
Nick Nick dominates oh my god three-way
tie for third place with Matt Andy oh
and Jose and there's a question for you
flip you've been called out by the
Twitterverse omiai WK asks how do i make
a flip style dashboard dials and gauges
well my style yeah that's a good
question
but I would definitely there's a there
are definitely dials and gauges as part
of that you know whole front end thing
in manipulate but you can also use them
to just display data as well the flip
style thing by the way would just be
yeah there you go
using gauges horizontal gauges I love
those circular gauges don't even need
numbers right right if you know of my
eye
in my youth I did a little car race
driving and as long as everything's
pointing up everything is great and the
minute that the thing is not pointing up
that's bad and so you know that's all we
need and hey we got our we got our
leaderboard back hippety with the
leaderboard Phillip here we go in first
place for question five was Nick with
three points Powell with two jose met
and in do all get one point this
question five had the most total points
of any yeah I feel good all right this
is a final question
final question question six correct yes
this is the final question
Jesse roll those dice hit that button
spin that wheel lon the klaxon I choose
a function from the Wolfram function
repository and write a new function
replicating or inspired by the original
so back to what we were saying before
the Wolfram function repository so yeah
we probably should show them you know
what that is and what that's all about
so many clickings yes there you go yeah
I'd open up my machine how did that
happen I understand it's magic this is
awesome so you can I'm guessing you
probably have some functions in here
Phillip oh yeah I got I got a couple in
here for you know things yeah I think
you can I think I try that norborne ox
oh yeah smooth step smoother step right
seconds today
no I didn't and I was thinking about
writing best step after this because
yeah it turns out smooth steps an old
computer graphics function and then
somebody came up with a thing called
smoother step and rather than change
smooth step they just created a thing
called smoother smoother stab yes yeah
yeah but I yes yes yes the smooth and
smoother step are terms of art and then
they basically are and they're
interpolation routines used in
computer graphics in a little bit of
trivia in tin toy the or no knick-knack
the film that should have been nominated
and wasn't in my opinion of it we've
ever nots B and I sat around and figured
out that we called a smooth step a
million and a half times per frame of
film and those 24 frames a second and it
was a I think it's a three minute or
four minute film so so you can figure
that out so this is you know one of
these things where it's like well what
should we optimize well I got the smooth
step is like was implemented in like
almost implemented in hardware I think
you know so yeah that's amazing I want
to show some Jessi functions but first
yeah that one's why didn't you file a
complaint about the flip function yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna register a trademark
or something yeah I should flip view
yeah Jesse has great stuff my stuff look
at this recent resource functions
doesn't that yeah how boy that might be
handy everyone this is awesome yeah see
what else looks fun for you Taliesin has
some good stuff in there too yeah but
but the tower is telling us to check on
Jesse's okay oh well yeah I was gonna
say he's flying who's flying the to this
no yeah yeah I have actually
Jesse I didn't realize that was yours so
kudos to you this is one so you can see
right it's got he's got a byline up
there but when you just use the function
you don't get to see who implemented the
function so oh you did it with Bob okay
all right still it doesn't matter it's
Jesse's function this is really nice
that's a cool one yeah you know I've
been looking for something like this
this is really cool so how does this
work you put in a button select and hit
okay is this doing what I think it does
Wow holy moly also you can specify which
cells that's the beautiful thing
gotcha
something you can build a notebook and
you want them to work together this is a
very useful function yeah yeah boy
there's so much to learn here this is
amazing so someone asked does
Mathematica have a built-in greens
function anywhere and of course if you
type greens function and the resource
that you know that might exist and then
you could search it in the documentation
as well look at this one persist
resource function so every time you do a
resource function right here it persists
as somewhat anyway this one now it
becomes a built-in like look at this you
just give it the name of another
resource function oh that's a first
and now there's a built-in function yeah
yeah nice that's amazing nice nice yeah
that's what we've all needed if that's a
good one because it drives me crazy to
have to type the extra two characters to
get my whenever I need to use smooth
step and so I actually have smooth step
in my own init file so I don't have to
do that but now with Jesse's persistent
resource function I don't need my stupid
thing that's that's really great looks
like I'm a submission oh he created an
anagram nice nice nice
exactly anagram good yes sanitize the
data do that contains exactly that's
really nice very cool jesse has just
carefully well we get here eight point
six billion calls to smooth to the
smooth step function in knick-knack so
you think and by the way that's yeah if
at some point it's worth cutting because
he used quantities which is a very
useful thing right names per second in
that awesome yeah yeah
remind me you're royalty is $1 per use
right yes yeah actually the sad thing is
I think the guy who wrote I'm trying to
remember well I think it was Ken Perlin
who wrote a smooth step originally so
yeah he's the poor guy who's not getting
paid anymore
yeah we have a second solution it's it's
I don't know but my mom's polish and she
would tell me sign degree nice so I
gotta tell you people you guys are doing
a good job of living up to the spirit of
getting good votes so this is you're
getting so here's our sign degree right
right okay okay and the same answer 90
yeah there we go maybe it could be now
by the way you can show them that they
can download the source code for as a
notebook right
so to see if someone just you know
plagiarized not that I'm accusing anyone
of doing anything Umbro let's actually
that would be useful we have another
solution but just well yeah an arcsine
yeah we saw the one-liner solution for
here that was great yeah get over here
it's one of those it's stuck between
universes yeah well we have two new we
have two mortared solutions so we'll
call will call off the solutions at 543
544 we'll call off the solutions I just
wanted to point that out it is the same
it's the 180 over PI but why you might
want to use a function resource function
and doing yourself it is they it has
attributes like listable it says it's a
numeric
it'll catch certain kinds of errors
right there's just a lot that goes into
making it production quality it still
maybe not at the level of you know
unbreakable nough says the built-in
Wolfram language function but it just
has a little bit more in it so if you
have a choice bits like one night I use
all the time is ensure directory right
oh yeah right yeah yeah write that
yourself all the time right yeah it's
better to just use the one that's that
are built okay next solution so we saw
Oh add indices look at that one Jose
sent in so we have Joe Bob else and we
have Jose's yeah you look at this one
add indices no we didn't let's look this
is second one by Jose here no no no no
no no no this is Jose's add indices
let's see did likes a list and you would
add the indices to the beginning of the
list that's yeah maybe this is more
useful to you sometimes fantastic and
the next one is by I think Matt is that
right that's what I'm seeing in my Nick
I think that's five correct you know oh
I don't have one from Nick but that's
probably oh okay yeah yeah yeah new verb
nice new verbs so for a part of speech
if it's a member yes by the way very
smart Matt not capitalizing the end
because otherwise you might have thought
it was a new verb q there's one of these
birds that was just recently added to
the dictionary very good and you can you
avoid collision with the built-in
namespace but that's a you know depends
on who you're talking I actually name
them I tend to name things with capitals
because I'm you know or I put or I use
like a code in Frey I tend to use
packages a lot I I write my own name
spaces so just to make that stuff this
is good so this is pretty great this is
what it does to this input this by Nick
I think is our last mission yes here's
his functions called prettier grid
maybe I need to evaluate cutting off
because that could be terribly ugly grid
oh he's so look he's putting he's kind
of busy
he's got a busy a curve where he is
putting the points for the see where
he's trying to put the control points in
strange Bayesian somebody yeah yeah now
you're just perfect it's a great great
what's your problem yeah yeah now to me
that's great
that was Nicks and I think that's the
last one let's just count so we have
Nick with prettier grid have matt with a
new verb cue we have jose with add
indices with arcsine degree and Jo with
anagram cue and I think yes there at the
pole is live the pole is live ladies and
gentle oh yeah I'm writing a short
function one that's very specific to my
domain a lowercase it but if I'm writing
one and I've done this for years even
before there was a function this
function maybe someone on earth might
sometime use again then I tend to
capitalize it yeah yeah yeah that's and
thus why I tend to use contexts and you
know to for the same reason but yes
there is a definitely style there are
strong feelings about style let's just
put it down but yeah no I agree with you
I think that's right so let's see here
so Pavel doing doing the about to crush
crushing Nick Joe making us a run at
least vote for yourself Jose come on
yeah yeah yeah hop on Twitch
[Laughter]
I liked your Soze that was good yeah no
exactly okay there's gonna pair we all
oh man what happens if it's a five way
tie for first yeah that I don't I don't
think it can be but you know let's go
I'm good with whatever happens right
because Nick I like that people are
trying to game it now right if you vote
Nick down it puts Jose because Jose can
get three and then be 10 to 11 right I
like I very much like that it's a tie
for first and Nick for third wow wow wow
so three four five six seven eight and
this one will be three plus three plus
two oh it's a tie so we have two
questions that are tied for most total
points yes very good
and I believe unless there's a tie this
will wrap it up yes yes I believe but
this is the thrilling conclusion Nick
you know I don't see him
I understand there's a so I was even
back yeah we and and we need to we need
to talk to Danielle and Aaron we need a
large novelty check I think would be the
next because the wrestling yes it's in
the virtual mail okay perfect perfect
because the the wrestling belt for those
of you especially on Twitch who are
unfamiliar at the developer conference
Danielle and Aaron found Dave there is a
beautiful wrestling belt that is given
to the winner there here we go flip
Gydesen
tell us what happened it looks like
ladies and gentlemen it looks like it's
Nick with 13 points well done Nick
Paulo and Jose tied at 8 for second Matt
with 7 in 4th place
Joe with 5
and Andy Oh bringing it up with two so
there's situations have yes everybody
everybody go back very good job
this is a man hi this is great yeah very
cool
yes I totally agree let's go let's go to
the tower
let's see where the tower is giving no
no no tie your what you said was right
yeah first second and second yes right
great so and then so the and and I
believe I believe Danny there is a
handsome I saw earlier flying through
the email handsome certificates to be
delivered to the winner I don't know
there are three winners are they here in
the zoo yeah yeah yeah Cameron there's
Nick somebody yeah experience like give
us some feedback how was it does fun I
can't even describe it you already great
commentators this year is this your
first summer school yeah that was my
first it's so like yeah good point good
point yeah it's great and well
congratulations yeah you should
definitely consider coming to the
developer conference and competing for
competing for the big money of at the
developer conference has donated up to 1
billion iterations of smoother step for
your use free yeah anything you like
yeah with no royalties free
Bravo - Nick Nick did a great job I'm
particularly a fan of the comic sans and
the off-centered numbers
that was inspired the fact that you did
that in real time too it's very
impressive excuse it is style close
enough Phil if you stop screen sharing
then everybody can see people video yeah
good point yeah
so go ahead Nick Nick say hi and so that
it all right yeah there we go
now people on the twitch can see Nick
and his awesome background yeah that
virtual or real it was the first time I
participated in some kind of going
competition so I was a little bit used
to this kind of little programming code
because I was really into a warrant
challenges for the school but I wasn't
sure if I was doing right participating
but it's been so fun awesome and thank
you for bringing that up flip how can we
have forgotten to mention Wolfram
challenges that's it yeah that's right
no go so that's a great sign I love it
it's there's so many great question just
go to the start here start there I still
have many many of them oh yeah Thank You
Jose that's wonderful Joe tell us about
hey this was a really awesome coding
competition I love the questions that
were chosen and everybody had such
awesome answers it was really
interesting to see what you guys did so
yeah this is a this was really fun I
think this is probably my third coding
competition although this was the first
one where it was like really fast-paced
and super head-to-head we actually had
like a leaderboard on this one but
that's that's really interesting and I
thought it made it all
much more fun so thanks guys great
thanks and that's a big shout out
actually specifically to Jesse yes top
architect Jesse who will be forced to
reveal himself at some point I should
call this the Jesse Friedman from life
challenge well in addition he figured
out how to get all of these questions
into Mathematica notebooks for us
instantaneously which is some wizardry
that I had never seen and if you've been
on slack in summer school
you can notice he's like a quantum
particle he's in like three ten twenty
different threads at once simultaneously
right yeah yeah yeah how do you context
switch that fast let alone answer it
incredible there's Pavel as I love the
frosty look you've got going there
that's pretty awesome pretty 1990 in my
[Music]
case I had some fun with you it was
pretty pretty nice first time for me as
well what happened there you're muted
you're muted yeah someone unmute Andy
yeah also a first coding competition so
I learned a lot from everyone
Congrats to Nick and everyone so yeah
pliable firm summer school I seriously
seriously awesome people should apply oh
yeah it's you know the the thing I miss
though is and the food at my house is
better than the dorm food usually at
where some of the places we have to do
or through this door food is peak
cuisine yeah yeah I know
I'm with it Jesse will you please unmute
yourself so that we can all see you
there is there isn't usually a camera in
the control room so I wasn't expecting
this
man yeah this was fun I'm glad all of
you had fun and appropriate thanks
should go to some of the people who who
put together the the tech system that
drives this competition those on the
livestream didn't get to see it but
there's a there's an interface the
competitors use to submit their answers
and that was originally done by JW and
Brian V and the documentation systems
group at Wolfram I just made some tweaks
and changes as needed over the past two
years that we've done this competition
so yeah thanks to them yeah great work
everybody else behind the scenes we
really appreciate it it's hard to
imagine seeing it but there's a lot of
work that goes into the twitch and the
zooms I'm coordinating everything so
Scott and Avery yeah Thank You Danielle
Brandon Danielle can you come on and
tell us what we do now what do we do
with our lives um take a bow
seriously both of you it was fantastic
and amazing and thank you for everything
that all of you have done for it
I've been sitting here cracking up for
the last hour I can't say more than
thank you and we can let the students
get back to building their projects
because this is a fun break but they
still have lots of work to do well great
I had a great time Phillip this was a
[Music]
pure pleasure to work with you yes and
hopefully we'll we'll get to do this
again soon
maybe I just I hope we get to do it in
person of together soon that wouldn't be
it would be perfect time for now